stamford connecticut is a city that has
a vast variety of restaurants
smack in the center of town is
sabatello's an italian eatery opened
three years ago by its owner sammy
setembre
known for his once successful pizzeria
sammy has been struggling with this
venture and is only months from closing
how we doing guys i was eight years old
when i started i worked at my brother
benny's restaurant starting at making
pizza i always had a dream of a really
nice restaurant hey how are you how you
doing i make everybody feel like a super
summer to come to subway dolls because
i'm a superstar and that's why my name
is on there it's all about me how are
you tonight
good thank you you're welcome i've been
with sammy for two and a half years and
the restaurant was really busy all the
time and it slowly
declined now we need some customers i
know i can't believe this usually have a
couple tables
we have an awesome beautiful place i
think the decor is excellent i don't
know why people are not eating here the
food is good [ __ ] kills me where is
this guy it was hard as a rock and it
tastes disgusting if you think there's
something else to complain about please
get me i'll be downstairs
the nightmare at sabatiellos it's sammy
he can be really nasty dumb the [ __ ]
go to work if not go to [ __ ] all hear me
calamari to be honest with you it was
edible that was about it they got to
have a microphone with you i don't want
everybody to hear it
i think that if sammy doesn't change i
don't think it would make it another
year
right
the [ __ ] out of here
damn i eat meatballs in here why we put
so many meatballs screws you a friend of
yours man you guys go bowling together
my restaurant's a nightmare because my
staff doesn't listen to me all the time
why are you gonna be a big shot with my
money bro be a big shot on your day off
thanks bell
i never talk
i presently have over a million dollars
in debt to this restaurant i have a
house on the line and um i cleaned out
my savings everything rides on this
place 25 or 125 125. you sure sammy he's
very stressed out when i look at him
knowing him for so many years i can see
a different person he's just not as
happy as he used to be he should have
been a [ __ ] mailman swear to god i
waited my whole life to step up to this
plate which is this really nice
restaurant you know and if i lose this
restaurant i lose my life because my
restaurant is my life
as gordon walks through stanford he
catches up on sabatello's most recent
food reviews
right food review sabotelhos food
mediocre don't get robbed the owner is
the most obnoxious human being i've ever
dealt with two-star food at four-star
prices here we are how are you good how
are you yeah well dee thank you let me
get you a table maybe go upstairs and uh
have white to eat yeah i'll show you
some upstairs let me get a menu i wasn't
really nervous when chef ramsay came to
the restaurant because i make the best
tiny food in the world i'm awesome and
it speaks for itself i can't wait to
look around oh my god look at this
isn't it inviting nice and warm it is
nice and warm so if the decor is nice
and warm
the host is nice and warm it must be all
about the food right my food is good my
food is very good so um what would you
recommend for lunch
my lasagna is homemade all this is fresh
right yes everything else is fresh it's
not fresh we don't sell it the soup of
the day is a it's a wedding soup
consists of vegetables and little mini
meatballs it's really nice actually the
best balls in town
it's awesome people love it
okay when chef ramsay sat down the first
thing i thought man this guy's gonna be
surprised he's definitely gonna do some
kind of cartwheels after eats his food
he's got he's got a few items he wants
so we start off with this soup of the
day i'm going to try the lasagna that's
homemade and then finally i'll finish up
with a new york strip how do you want
that cooked mid-rare steak red
take away excuse me please and how long
have you been here david three years
three years wow did you put his order
did you put his order in so he i'm
talking to you i just want to make sure
you take over yeah yeah that's fine okay
so
why does he interrupt you like that ah
sometimes in the middle i'm giving like
specials oh i'm sorry i'm i gotta uh
bring dave i'm like damn i'm talking to
the people they feel like what's the
matter with him of course that's not
nice that's not nice at all sami he got
no manners and i think somebody got to
teach him how he got to be when he's
working
give me first the lasagna and then
you're going to give me the sirloin
steak you know what he said make it nice
please you got that wedding suit right
yes yes
well that was quick
[Music]
lovely
[Music]
it's hideous like a mismatch of bits of
[ __ ] put together and brought to the
ball
and anemic gray meatballs in there
how was your soup
yeah that's a wedding suit that's to get
him in the mood to get married jesus i'd
rather get [ __ ] divorced
oh my god and that's made fresh every
day is it normally our soups last two
days two days
how could it be super the day when it's
soup of yesterday
and it's sort of it's bland anyway
hopefully hopefully the other dishes
will be better
thank you
soup of the day
[Music]
you said the soup soup is blend is not
good
that soup was two days old but that
doesn't mean it's garbage you know what
i'm saying what is your [ __ ] health
department critic
oh my god
jeffrey says the soup is not good well i
can't throw the soups out that's the
rules
what i want you to do is take two
lasagnas out put them in the mic
make sure that lasagna is nice and hot
manny i told him it's my homemade
lasagna my signature item okay do the
right thing
lasagna please manny got this one
[Music]
wow here's your lasagna homemade lasagna
oh jesus look at that someone drop it
jesus
here we've got like white bits of
chicken or veal but there seems to be
something slightly synthetic and plastic
inside that tastes absolutely hideous if
that is homemade i'll [ __ ] dance in
this restaurant tonight start bothered
naked that
is not homemade holy crap
with the steak
thank you what is that in there
that's the uh ground beef that's beef it
looks like canned dog food
ask the chef where the uh recipe's from
if it's homemade
there's almost a recipe
which one which one do you want to know
uh if it's a homemade lasagna where you
get the recipe
my mother and where you put ground beef
on that what was this cause it's a
tangle design it's not a goddamn chinese
lasagna
[Music]
it's
a tough steak
not seasoned
greasy
the food is consistent
consistently poor
what a shame
okay i'm done that's full of grease
where the things come from who buys them
is that sammy
yep the food is really really bad in all
aspects
we've been trying to tell this army for
a long time but of course because we are
the employees
you don't listen having had a good taste
of some bad dishes gordon heads to the
kitchen to meet with sammy and head chef
jose hey guys
how you doing
let's go through it together shall we
yeah soup was hideous
how old is that soup the soup has been
like uh three days with me yeah three
days with you yeah it tasted like it
it tasted disgusting bland
and everything was cooked to [ __ ]
the lasagna let's quickly go on to that
that was unique
uniquely [ __ ]
[Music]
that's homemade where is it
lasagna is over there yeah can you get
me a portion why was it dry in the
middle of the sauce sure we proportioned
it we cut them
it's frozen
he said it says it's frozen how old is
that that's the lasagna i make the last
week of priority we make three drizzles
on a time and then we proportion then we
freeze
we take some up as we need them okay so
it's not fresh that's what i'm trying to
say but doesn't mean it's bad
does it mean it's bad
i'm italian man here's a guy from
scotland the [ __ ] he know about lasagna
does any chef throw food away if it's
not bad
answer that mr ramsay any chef yes yeah
hello are you gonna throw it away should
i answer it or are you gonna [ __ ] no
[ __ ] tell me good [ __ ] tell me are
you getting upset now no not at all yeah
not at all a little bit maybe every
[ __ ] chef i know makes lasagna fresh
every day
when chef ramsay started critiquing
telling all these bad things about my
food i feel like what is this guy out of
his mind then the biggest disappointment
was the steak who buys the steak that's
the toughest steak i've ever eaten i've
dropped down on the steaks because my
business has dropped it was a choice
steak it's not my black angus you're
right i love the way you got excuses for
everything
i couldn't do anything right it was it
was amazing it was very hard for me to
swell i could i couldn't believe it he
said everything i did was wrong you're
very pumped up i never thought cause i
believe we have good stuff yeah are you
asking me or telling me i'm telling you
i think maybe you walk up uh on the
wrong side of the bed
i get out the same side of the bed every
day i know what the [ __ ] i'm talking
about and that food was bland i can't
believe you're telling me my food sucks
i can't believe it i i honestly think
you're out of your [ __ ] mind
it ain't there's nothing wrong with it
yeah there's nothing wrong i think
you're a little too critical over
critical the minute you get down off
your high horse and start understanding
what the [ __ ] wrong with this place
then we might have something compatible
to work with are you finished are you
done am i done i can't believe it i've
just started unbelievable
okay i'm gonna clear my head i wanted
some uh some [ __ ] i need some fresh
air yeah let me show you where the door
is
i'll go through that one there excellent
he could take the [ __ ] out of me and
just like really broke my balls and this
guy's out of control yeah i think
someone needs to put him in line let me
tell you something man for a guy to talk
like that in front of me like that i
can't believe it
and he's still alive and we didn't shoot
him [ __ ] kill that guy
after a night filled with sami's excuses
gordon decides to take a closer look at
the kitchen
right
[Music]
this place is spotless
absolutely spotless
amazing
[Music]
raw chicken and cooked chicken
[Music]
where's sammy what the [ __ ] that
what is that
called chicken novella when were they
cooked
sunday will do those chickens
can you get me sammy please
yeah
[ __ ] you now
same [ __ ] different town
sammy having a quick look around the
kitchen
uh the place is spotless sure
very clean kitchen's immaculate we try
unfortunately the [ __ ] i found in the
fridge what's this have a look at this
that's not the way we cook is it what we
got chicken francese there yeah
cooked sat there
yeah what's the matter with
what's the matter with it what's that
set next to that's a grilled chicken
marinade we do it for sandwiches and for
salads that's raw chicken sammy
we can't put them closer by each other
oh come on
i know you want to mouth off and tell me
how [ __ ] wrong i am and i'm a [ __ ]
meatballer but that's appalling what's
this here
it gets worse what the [ __ ] is that and
why is it cool because we have to make
it raw and bake it in the oven so take
too long the customers are not gonna
wait they're gonna leave well customers
aren't here so how can they leave
they're not here to begin with
it's a nice dish people like it it's
[ __ ]
no it comes in like it [ __ ] doesn't
stink and i was trying to be prepared
but it gets my blood rolling and he's
out of [ __ ] control can you do me a
favor can you get rid of the cooked meat
and put them with cooked meat and the
raw meat with raw meat before he [ __ ]
kills someone she's right he's ready
argue back i'm dying holy crap
you know you know that bro jose you're
killing me my kitchen stamp they're not
doing their job everybody wants to do
something their own way and there's only
one chief and that's me oh my god
[Music]
four for dinner yes please main course i
gotta stop fillet of salt stuffed with a
crab meat the uh new york stream
dinner service night is gonna be
outstanding and i wanna show chef ramsey
that we really do know how to make good
stuff jose i'm waiting for table three
is that salt almost ready
thank god
what's this soul stuff with jose i'll do
vegetables
you crabby imitation crab meat yeah
why imitation
crap me it's too special
[Music]
i like fresh and stuff in the house well
sami don't let me do it anybody gotta
follow what he says how uh how can we
have a special soul stuffed with fake
crab meat no it's not all fake we we uh
jose you you told me the crabby speak
there you should grab me i
i can't wait what kind of [ __ ]
you're gonna come back with now no no
[ __ ] at all normally we do put the
lump cranby we do 28 you taking the
[ __ ] fifth out of centre we all make
mistakes you know maybe i cut some
corners but don't call me a liar or a
cheat or a dishonest guy i wouldn't be
this far being a liar cheating
dishonestly so i think you should
[ __ ] take it back oh you're making me
look horrible in front of this guy
you're my number one guy right
son of a [ __ ]
i'm sorry
okay i'm sorry
what's the matter with this say it's not
fresh
but it's [ __ ] watery
i'm dead i'm busy
not bad though it's not bad
not bad
oh no come on he puts it out it's not
bad
you're [ __ ] delusional no no it's not
it's it's mushing it's water
and it's [ __ ] disgusting you'll jump
them down like a big [ __ ] baboon and
it's good
i think we need great food if i didn't
make great food i wouldn't be here so
for this [ __ ] to [ __ ] tell me that
i'm not doing good and really pissed me
off to be honest with you
[Music]
watching this restaurant perform is
embarrassing fake [ __ ] crab meat
insider stole it's pretty obvious it's
become the appendix of restaurants in
stamford you just want to get rid of it
and get it out
[Music]
oh sorry
i think i'd like to have it just a
little bit more done a little more
yeah
what's the matter
a little more a little bit what's wrong
with it cold in the middle
okay put in the microwave let's put the
microwave put it in a minute and a half
[Music]
go back on right now
let's
i kind of got the idea that maybe
someone just took this plate because the
plate's pretty warm and maybe just stuck
back into the microwave instead of
putting the lamb chops back into a pan
yes thank you
[Music]
[ __ ] busting my ball now wait let me
see it now it's too much cookie before
it's too [ __ ] rare and now it's too
much
how do they want the meat the first time
oh my god how did he want to cook tommy
i don't know i'm gonna [ __ ] ask the
lady you know
with food now coming back it's a perfect
opportunity for gordon to witness
sammy's customer service skills how did
you want your nico
would you want a rear and you want some
medium so can we make you another one
will you wait or you don't want it at
all wait but the thing is is i don't
want you to stick it back in a microwave
no we're gonna throw that on make your
new one nobody's talking about microwave
you're the ones talking about microwave
they came out of a microwave otherwise
they won't be like exuding do you work
for a microwave company you know so much
about microwave
[Music]
unbelievable
unbelievable
[ __ ] out of here it's all take a hike
[ __ ] told me we went to a microwave
i'm gonna make fun of let her wait
better wait now i know this lady wanted
a free meal or whatever i thought it was
a total nightmare i kept my composure i
wanted to kill her and i did jose not
your fault the lamb is tough
there's even [ __ ] tools to work with of
course you're going to create [ __ ] food
here's a landmarker
bring it to come on
[Music]
[Applause]
no wait folly not done yet i want to see
you cut into it
how is it is it still too rare you know
what i'm done no more chances
unbelievable
oh my god i just wanted to pick her up
and throw her out there's a a right way
and a wrong way of handling something
like that and she was totally wrong she
sends her back three [ __ ] times
asking how does she want to go go out
there and apologize to them i don't want
to apologize i don't give a [ __ ] let it
go get sick of it go out and apologize
for them i'm actually really embarrassed
that he that he made a scene with one of
the customers tonight regardless of what
happened the customer is always right in
a customer service business so [ __ ]
mad it sucks
i'm like so upset inside i'm [ __ ]
fumigating tonight you look like a jerk
off for this [ __ ] it's a real job
tonight you know so don't leave make
another shut everything [ __ ] down and
forget it i don't really give a [ __ ]
shut it down don't [ __ ] do nothing
so [ __ ] mad tonight you look like a
jerk off for his [ __ ]
after a frustrating evening in the
kitchen and in the front of house sammy
has hit his breaking point you know so
don't [ __ ] make another shut
everything [ __ ] down and forget it i
don't really give a [ __ ] shut it down
it was uh one of the worst nights of my
life and uh i wanted to strangle the
customers tonight i wanted to strangle
my guys especially in the kitchen
everybody it was just a total nightmare
it was a mess
ladies thank you very much thank you
thank you guys i'm sorry that's right
it's not your fault thank you for being
so understanding
i really appreciate it i'm the person
that apologizes for sammy because he
won't do it and i don't want his
reputation to be any worse than i guess
people already see it i can't believe
this i i can't believe it
all the time does this the same story
all the time the same problem something
he don't care
[ __ ] mostly i feel so mad i feel so
hurt i can't get my staff to listen i
feel like running away tell your truth
[Music]
after an unusual evening in which sammy
shut down his own restaurant gordon has
now confirmed the source of the problems
at sabatellos 58 customers we served
908
5 8
i've never seen 58 covers
done in such a difficult way you know
that
is that normal for you to go to the
kitchen like that and talk to them like
that if i didn't go on at all forget
about it we wouldn't have 20 entrees
come back you've got no right as an
owner to be so selfish to start picking
on [ __ ] stuff or blaming customers
the problem
is with you
come on are you serious you agitate
customers you agitate staff why so
negative what do you mean negative i try
to keep these guys happy i was in there
trying to that's happy
are you kidding me guys you're making
mistakes like well you gotta go back to
school
you said all this is about me the the
way the place is going wrong nobody
talks to me like that people come here
because of me people love my food sammy
i'm here to help i see a guy that's
passionate about running a restaurant
but [ __ ] clueless you're the hardest
individual to work with my friend
and each and every one of your staff are
[ __ ] scared to tell you that you
handicap the kitchen a menu far too big
with two cooks in there and you've got
such [ __ ]
imitation material on here they can't
cook it what do you mean imitation
material that steak's not [ __ ] black
angus 1855.
we used to carry black inks it's what
you're charging for now sammy it's not
about you used to
28 for a stuffed rolled [ __ ] fillet
of soul with fake crab hey
you're a bullshitter
yeah i made some mistakes i cut a couple
corners why i'm in a [ __ ] tough spot
right now what the [ __ ] he would do it
too no look at the level of false
advertising on your menu and stop taking
the piss out of you and stamford
did you forget anything that's it
it's all this is about me of course it
is
i've got to rethink
i've got some [ __ ] ideas and some
plans i've got to get going quickly
but i want you to do one thing
take your head out your [ __ ] and get
[ __ ] real with me
good i'll see you in the morning good
night
stubborn
[ __ ] i don't need this jerk off to
[ __ ] tell me about how i run my
business don't tell me that all this is
because of me he's full of [ __ ] [ __ ]
i didn't like that
and next time that i see him in person
i'm gonna [ __ ] tell
[Music]
it's a new day and gordon has come up
with a plan to get sammy back on track
how are you good yeah good sit down you
look uh pissed like you're ready for a
fight do you think i'm here to fight
no i don't i think you have good
intentions you're a tough guy to get
through to i know i know you've got this
defense mechanism that no one seems to
break down i came in early this morning
to sort of talk to you to sort of try to
get through so
i want you to take me back to the
beginning i need to know more about
sammy ten years ago you ready yes
holy mackerel how did you get this
picture because i had these under under
locking key that's the better i like at
the bottom only my own business
succeeding by 35. uh i always loved the
restaurant business working for my
brother since i was small nine years old
making dough to making sandwiches and
eventually making pizza
which brings me into this oh my god my
brother benny passed away seven years
ago actually get me all choked up here
this man's a hero in your life right
he's the one that really got me
motivated i love him he was like more of
a father
i mean i would do anything for him he
was awesome can you miss him totally
because like uh like now i could i would
love to call him and
ask for some advice it's like i don't
know where to turn all has to come for
me i'm like i'm bombarded everywhere
i can't believe you got that picture
there you go
this was a huge success this thing
that's how i made my money that's how i
i bought my house and greenwich that's
how i i got this now i feel like
everything is uh
draining me i'm trying to keep this
afloat it's not a little place anymore
over there was smaller overhead i had
less people maybe had more control over
it now it's like
i don't know
look at that
you remember that day like it was
yesterday right yes
russian tour gives students a taste of a
career in the kitchen
your life
that's you in your mentoring tutoring um
prolific position now look at the way
you were dealing with your staff and
your customers last night and you know
it's [ __ ] night and day and that's
where i need to connect in there that's
sammy
not today sammy i need your support but
more importantly i need to get you back
in love with the restaurants
okay i
listen you got my word not 110 i'm gonna
give you 220
i want that same feeling back i want to
be that same sam it's sad that i wait
this long
thank you please
thank you very well thank you also
chef ramsay and what he did really open
up my eyes i feel like
something's brewing something's going
something's moving it's the best thing
i've felt in a long time to be honest
with you
now that sammy is focused once again
gordon has begun to make some menu
changes for tonight's dinner service
straightforward lasagna first off a
small amount holiness sauce two nice
layers
a little bit of mozzarella in the middle
heavy ricotta on top nothing gets put in
the freezer in the oven now okay so
we'll do a grill filet mignon table side
a little bit of thyme on there and we're
gonna roast it now in the oven she goes
some potatoes
and brussels sprouts now that gordon has
shown them how to prepare tonight's
specials he is looking for the front of
the house to create some excitement in
the dining room here we go two nice
slices not thin slices
up lift
bang and away and present
great
this is just
one small measure of you personally
reaching out and doing something
different here sabotage has never done
table side so we're excited about it
actually i'm very excited i got my
confidence back i got my balls back i
got my lasagna back on track it's going
to be great tonight
[Music]
with news that gordon ramsay is in town
sabatello's is busier than it has been
in years
but only time will tell if we'll see the
volatile sammy or the personable
friendly sammy i'm going to totally have
an awesome night tonight when people
walk out tonight they're going to be
thinking wow is that sammy what a
difference we got two specials for
tonight we got a nice baked lasagna also
i got a nice black angus filet mignon
you don't even need a steak knife by the
way i tried the filet mignon okay okay
take your time i'm very excited for
tonight i feel comfortable to go to the
tables and sell the food we're gonna get
yeah the delay thank you how are we
doing jose you're doing that 13 table 13
and what about 15. you had one for 15
which is three
this man has to talk he doesn't open up
i know i know he only in one hour's time
we're gonna be [ __ ] look uh jose come
on man hold me up
don't rush me to get to tape wow when
you're rushed nothing's good
thank you bro all right up the stairs
please be careful is this your medium
actually you know what that's really
rare
well i'm going to cook a little more yes
that's what i thought i'm sorry no
problem
just give me a few minutes all right oh
no the medium
oh come on
for [ __ ] sake this is supposed to be
medium bro come on don't let me down
jose come on quick
he's like completely behind already hi
my husband's steak is raw inside
do you want me to cook more
yep
[Music]
okay
you're welcome
you want a little cookie yes medium [ __ ]
i asked for medium put the spot gonna
grow on video
no no what happened you watch that
medium let's see what's it sound the
ticket
said medium just read the ticket pal
it's very simple although dinner service
started out with a very cool calm sammy
problems in the kitchen have brought out
the old sammy god damn it
he's doing the middle line he's serving
it all i'm tired of [ __ ] excuses i'm
taking all the blame here i look like a
[ __ ] jerk off this whole [ __ ] town
i'm tired of it
jose does not communicate trying to do
everything himself in turn slowing the
restaurant down and making me look bad
and making me go under i'm not gonna let
that happen jose just make the food damn
it
i'm [ __ ] believable
jose just make the food damn it although
sammy may have been the main cause of
the problems last night you don't lose i
lose i lose everything here tonight head
chef jose and the kitchen staff have dug
a hole for the restaurant that is
virtually impossible to get out of you
guys are not communicating that's why
he's so thankful you see one ticket ask
him what are you working on yes sis you
know call me let me know that you hear
me yes sami i got him i don't know
you're listening it was just a total
nightmare it was a mess it's a real mess
nobody had their act together nobody
knew what they were doing we kept
getting in the weeds we kept getting
behind
out in the dining room the customers
continue to feel the effects of the
problems in the kitchen you wanted to
cook a little more a little bit more
will be good for sure for you it's fine
i didn't i know you said you had a hard
time doing i'm i'm nick don't worry
thanks
no problem what's wrong
say medium
[ __ ]
[ __ ] you now
hey now listen you've got to listen to
me now it's not good enough jose medium
requested no more excuses come on you
gotta communicate then otherwise i'm
gonna lose my [ __ ] [ __ ] everything i
ever [ __ ] work for is being shot down
the tube and being laughing stock of
[ __ ] stanford who the [ __ ] wants that
we've been here for
jose let him do the vegetables damn it
man you don't let jose do all the work
because he's too goddamn slow we're
losing everything here he speaks spanish
talking to spanish i don't care yo can
you can we do 61. i can't it's not
cooked there's an meal do 63.
don't even let me finish your tickets
you have any [ __ ] funny you don't
even grab these tickets do 63. get it
going let's go already no
no we need it now you got it going it's
coming now yeah we need it now jose we
can't keep these people [ __ ] waiting
you're better than that jose
[Music]
goddard it was a disaster today this is
one of the worst nights i ride
[Music]
yeah sit down another night another
rough service and sabatello's is clearly
running out of time
the big issue here is the kitchen
you have had a relationship with that
guy for 13 or 14 years
it's like a married couple
you've switched off from each other you
bark
he
ignores i'm not happy with him you know
something i have been too lazy letting
him do everything and not checking up on
him i'm really starting opening my eyes
i can't count on this [ __ ] guy
anymore what other [ __ ] truth i can't
count on and tonight i thought it was
gonna be so easy with steaks you sent
the media out of the [ __ ] rear every
ring came back rare any [ __ ] can cook
steaks i'm glad you said i gotta do
something different you're absolutely
wrong the more comfortable i get with
this jerk off the more the more they
take advantage of me but i'll be honest
with you
he doesn't step up to the plate tomorrow
let him go get somebody to place it it
breaks my heart what all the [ __ ]
truth i'm tired of it that's what pissed
me is exactly what i wanted to hear in
the middle of service
i'm not gonna count on jose doing the
job anymore just sit back and let this
guy do what he want ain't happening it's
either make changes now or i fail i
don't want to fail
after witnessing two failed dinner
services gordon spent the night devising
a plan to alleviate the problems in the
kitchen let's discuss
menu
okay there we are well now the secret
behind this
is we're gonna streamline the menu we've
increased the meat we've brought down
the appetizers the greens the sides
desserts
look at the size of the menu jose that
is done
to the maximum ability of what we got to
cook out of from downstairs this new men
is gonna be more better for us to knock
all the food out it's gonna be easy for
me tomorrow we're gonna re-launch this
restaurant as a unique italian
steakhouse sammy what do you think
i'm blown away by we're an awesome menu
it's so much nicer it's smaller
it's more attractive got some really
nice entrees there really awesome
changing to an italian steakhouse
totally made a lot of sense because i
have too much competition i think now we
have something to show people whip
oozing quality freshness great steaks
great wine happy i'll mix that
excited excited okay good i was very
nervous had a lot of doubts
but after seeing the menu i'm not so
nervous anymore i feel more confident
and so prepared now to do something
different let's go
[Music]
with the relaunch dinner just hours away
gordon meets sammy and the staff to
introduce the new dishes on the menu
okay entrees this is our selling point
the besteka we've seen that it flew out
the kitchen
okay their 14-ounce bone in new york
steak look at it six ounce filet mignon
grilled lobster tail that for me is the
heartbeat of this restaurant if we can
establish that kind of excitement with
our italian steakhouse everything else
will follow suit that's our jewel dig in
have a taste get familiar with it and
push it unbelievable right try it chef
ramsay's menu compared to my menu is
totally
different mine was old school lookalike
it's perfectly cooked chef ramsay's menu
is so so innovative so different so new
i like it and i should have changed it a
long time ago
can i tell you right now i i want you
everybody to make their food like that
if not it's not acceptable
see where it's over there i want to be
the same all the time yeah all right and
and the appetizer i want to be the same
i told manny too and i'm telling you
because you know something man i can't
be nervous anymore where if i'm going to
keep this place i'm not going to keep it
i'm going to lose it hear me all right
enough this week
with this guy unbelievable man really
open up my eyes not to just do the same
[ __ ] thing over and over and look
what we got nobody give me fresh ideas
nobody helped me out listen what this
guy did thank god this guy came god
bless this guy you know that it's my
fault you know that sitting on my ass
not trying to make a change yeah okay
tonight i'm counting on jose the kitchen
has to function better has to happen in
the kitchen
i want it to work
with a brand new menu and a community
willing to give sabatellos another shot
hi how are you he's got some awesome
specials tonight homemade lasagna it's
now up to sammy to show what he's made
of okay and also the filet mignon is
really good i am so excited about
tonight
actually i'm nervous and excited but
it's a good nervous it's like having
little butterflies before you go on
stage what i recommend from the grill is
near the bisteka it's delicious with the
restaurant now focused on being an
italian steakhouse jose's ability to
cook meat is put to the test come on
jose
we're grilling steaks and we're cooking
to order yes show me it can be done yeah
big night got to talk i got it i got it
coming up we're gonna split the sticker
how do you like it medium medium well is
good okay
big big big night tonight it's relaunch
night and a couple of questions
unanswered can sammy run the ration the
way it should be run and can jose
deliver on a menu that can possibly save
this restaurant right now i don't know
welcome to sabotellos this is so good
it's like eminem's gonna melt right in
your mouth
enjoy sir guys enjoy i told the guys
this is our last hurrah if we don't do
it tonight i'm gonna lose everything
that i work hard for my family
responsibility to the community
everything all right i like the
six ounce play portobello um
as orders pile in you gotta start
setting some tables out or else we're
gonna be in the weeds the kitchen is
about to be put to the test and so is
sammy's patience that's a lot of pasta
make me another one we need to get this
kitchen up and running and getting the
food to the table a lot quicker you make
the encelada mediterranean not ready yet
did you make that sweetie butter back no
it's not ready can you fire it right
away you hear me club i hear you sir i
feel like i'm babysitting i hate [ __ ]
babysitting i got to babysit the staff i
got to babysit the kitchen it's more
like red red oh come on you've got to
listen to me now it's stone cold i don't
know why
i'm getting really nervous i want to
keep the customer happy please you
should be good cooking used to be fast
as hell i don't know what happened
getting old jose's not doing the work we
kept getting in the weeds we kept
getting behind
come with me
here's my worry
58 covers in second turn of service
tables coming through yes yes service
too slow but this is not normal this is
[ __ ] worse than spaghetti house is
that what you're doing no come on
[ __ ] out i think jose's kind of lost
his his sense of drive you know i guess
me being too hard on them i finally
realized that we need to help him out
show me it can be done yeah
with everything at stake sammy decides
to jump behind the line to help jose but
will he make it better or worse
good bye-bye i'll do it i'm gonna do
everything myself just give me that
level two when i'm over there i need you
not now [ __ ] i should do this long time
ago twelve hundred dollars in my pocket
it's okay here let's read the thing
oh my god jose kill me
son of a [ __ ] [ __ ]
watch out watch out oh [ __ ] me
it's relaunch night and knowing it's do
or die for sabatello's sammy has jumped
behind the line to help oh my god
son of a [ __ ] [ __ ]
thanks dummy time sucker
thank god that my kitchen guys are not
involved in any bombs or rockets or
decisions because we won't be in danger
put the meat back up you can't take it
all you're not [ __ ] superman
come on
waste of time hurry up put it
jose get it done all right you're
killing me damn it just want to get
through it tonight i [ __ ] had it i
got it dude do another ticket let me do
it let me do everything myself how much
longer would we have to wait for i'll
double check on the time but i i would
give it about 25 or 30 minutes
you're still waiting for that table at
the bar
what's that they got the full name
how could you get about
that the machine printed it out down
here exactly two minutes after you're in
the kitchen which which one you gotta
give me two medium rare bro you're the
right one i'll be confused now talk to
me speak do you understand what he's
saying does he understand what he's
saying i don't think he understands
thing talk them in chinese this is all
going to die here i'm not on that
[ __ ] side tonight so don't organize
we don't know [ __ ] if they need you back
there you should know what you're doing
it's coming i promise they're just they
just want to make sure it was my path it
was really frustrating for the six
people at the bar and they were sitting
at the bar waiting for their food and
that shouldn't happen
how how far behind is this coming out
right now
here it comes here it comes right up
after a long wait by many of the
customers gordon hopes the new dishes
will be worth the wait
enjoy guys
[Applause]
it's really good though
really good
very good
but this is absolutely delicious i can't
believe the change sabatello's relaunch
ended successfully primarily because
when the kitchen struggled early on
sammy jumped behind the line and helped
instead of spinning out of control
still shot with these guys
give me seven on the fly
hey hey to a better day at summer tell
us
all right hey good luck in the future
tonight making these changes to an
italian steakhouse it was a step in the
right direction and it was a new menu it
was our first time doing it there was a
few mistakes but we're moving forward i
think i think it's gonna
it's gonna only get better and help the
restaurant
i'm leaving here with a salmon i've
always wanted hey look at me seriously
big boy a man that's back in control he
knows exactly what to do move forward
and make those changes i'm gonna do my
very best yeah [ __ ] you now
thank you [ __ ]
take care when i first met chef ramsay i
thought he was an arrogant jerk they
said yes and then i kind of saw the way
he comes about it he really does care
and he made me realize i have a purpose
and he got something out of me that i
haven't had come out in a long time and
that's hunger creativity it's the will
of doing good again
take care
my god finally i honestly thought i'd
have to wait for a lunar eclipse before
that guy seriously got the message and
who knows sometimes miracles can happen